Ramadan Block Nummer 5 am Abend habe ich
noch das Geschirr ausgeräumt einfach aus
Faulheit damit ich es am nächsten Tag
nicht machen muss habe dann am nächsten
Tag ein Rezept Video abgedreht
anschließend hatten wir noch einen
Vorstellungsgespräch und ich habe im
Onlineshop gesehen was alles angekommen
ist und wir haben endlich wieder Granola
aus der Hut ist gerettet das schmeckt so
lecker und es hält gut satt hier waren
wir noch in der Autowaschanlage Disco es
hat so Spaß gemacht nicht dann habe ich
noch einen kurzen Abstecher zum Kikis
kitchen Store gemacht und natürlich im
Café auch noch was mitgenommen zum
fassen brechen waren wir dann bei meiner
Schwiegermutter eingeladen und das war
alles so lecker sie kann einfach so gut
kochen ja klar zack wurden mir die
Süßigkeiten geklaut auf jeden Fall habe
ich dann noch meine Wasserflaschen
getrunken und das war's auch schon